and now let's get reaction to the
growing calls to abolish eyes from Kelly
and Conway she's a counselor to
president Trump Kellyanne thanks so much
for being with us tonight
this is wild I have not seen anything
like this like we saw yesterday where
you had 625 675 people storm into the
heart Senate office building we're in
the tin foil blankets 500 getting
arrested we had sitting congresswoman
and Senators basically either getting
arrested as well or sympathizing and
agreeing abolish ice how concerned is
the administration that this could
actually galvanize the Democrats to turn
out to vote in November well folks
should be concerned if it actually ever
came to pass Laura because the
immigration customs and enforcement
agency in this nation is there to
enforce all immigration laws not just
deportation as Senator Gillibrand
incorrectly inaccurately states they're
there to protect all these laws and you
know what ice did just last year they
arrested 33,000 criminal aliens who
committed all kinds of crimes that would
be mind-numbing to your audience they
also seized almost 2,400 pounds of
fentanyl
I bet they're fine with that Kellyanne I
think they're fine with that but they
want it to be reek reek accountability
they said I'm not buying it
I'm not buying it they want to pick and
choose their acronyms I I disagree with
that there's no evidence that they
believe that you can quote reimagine it
this is not the it's a small world
attraction at Disney well you're not
reimagining ice you're letting them do
their jobs by keeping criminal aliens
out and by enforcing all the immigration
laws at the put out our places of work
and our places of Education at the
welfare offices I believe Laura that
when you get past the talker abolish ice
which is becoming the leftward lurch for
the Democratic Party it seems including
this week it borders on if you get past
that do they really know what they're
saying to me it spans the spectrum of
from the ignorant to the irrational if
you listen to what they're actually
saying and they're trying to outflank
each other on the left for 2020 as well
they should not be
sizing this at a time when these are
very serious matters also I think some
of these folks who have a right to
protest I guess unless they were
arrested some of them are calling really
for Anarchy over authority so we should
listen they can't have it both ways they
can't pick and choose what they want to
happen on the altar of a of a convenient
political soundbite and yet at the same
time pretend that ice didn't did not
detect and and take secure enough
fentanyl last year synthetic opioid
fifty times the potency of heroin all I
wanted was a policy of morphine
you know they can't pretend that ice
didn't protect that was enough to kill
every American and that fentanyl last
year they cease to kill I want to move
on to what happened yesterday obviously
a horrific shooting in Annapolis another
heart breaker guy with a vendetta
against a newspaper filed a defamation
claim he seems completely like a kook
total whack-job stalked another woman
the president the president obviously
has had a I've had a pretty difficult
relationship with the press press has
been wildly unfair to this
administration on issue after issue yet
the language the president is used
against the press has led a lot of
people in the press to say look this
didn't cause what happened but deranged
people can get triggered by this type of
constant drumbeat that they're the enemy
of the state and etc etc that the worst
problem the country has is the president
reconsidering some of that language and
light of what happened yesterday well
the President did one of the things he
does best today Laura at his tax on Jobs
Act six-month anniversary he paused at
the very beginning to express sympathy
and grief for the victims and their
families an outrage over what had
happened and when you read a lot of the
print the print coverage I've read today
it's very clear that people at the paper
said if this person the shooter ever
comes in here call nine-one-one the
former editor said that he had never met
anybody so angry as a journalist in all
of his life so they knew that this guy
was bad news for them he had sued them
unsuccessfully many years ago and went
back yesterday to commit the ultimate
act of violence violence should not be
an occupational hazard they remove of
your life should not be an occupy
in Hazzard if you work in this
administration if you work in journalism
if you work anywhere and and that I
think is what the president is saying I
look I'm just somebody who's called for
tamping down the rhetoric for a very
long time but those who actually call
for it sometimes if you listen carefully
enough you look at their own social
media feeds they give they give license
sometimes to something I think is a
little bit hotter than covering the next
story
reporting the quote facts so but this
president as he has want to do calls out
violence and evil for what it is
including and what happened to those law
here's one sin Americans yesterday I get
but whether if someone's calling the
president evil or not C or a ridiculous
ridiculous rhetoric horrible stuff what
they've called him and then enemies they
like a lot I don't like it I don't
really like any of it and I think that
it all can be cleaned up you can have a
tough relationship aggressive
relationship that's fine it should it
should be tough and fair but I just
think all of it has gotten way out of
line but lately agree I've been saying
it for a very long time and and look we
I think you and I are speaking as very
tough women but also mothers and people
just want folks to disagree respectfully
as our press secretary said last week
Kellyanne we haven't one more really
important topic which is of course
what's going to happen in Helsinki which
is a meeting between the president and
Vladimir Putin I happen to think it's a
great idea to engage with a with a major
world power regardless of our
adversarial relationship with them at
times but listen to what happened today
with Joe Reid and others let's watch
well it's official Donald Trump is
finally getting one of the things that
he seemed to want the most drop is
scheduled to hold a summit meeting with
Vladimir Putin the president today again
cited Vladimir Putin's assurances that
Russia definitely didn't intervene in
our presidential election
why don't we believe him when he says so
the White House also today confirmed a
one-on-one summit between President
Trump and Vladimir Putin to take place
next month in Helsinki hold on to your
Alaska Kelly on your reaction they used
to want us to talk to the Soviets back
in the 70s and 80s let's all get along
the Soviets now we can
never meet with Putin apparently has
been a big switch there because Donald
Trump's name is involved of course Laura
this is very simple this is a president
who just came off a historic summit with
Kim in Singapore trying to denuclearize
the Korean Peninsula this is somebody's
pulled us out of the Iran deal so
they're not so that their nuclear
capability is this is somebody is
diminished this is somebody who has
already expelled Russian officials from
this country and put sanctions on Russia
when when it's been necessary and also
pushed back on Vladimir Putin when he
was propping up Assad not once but twice
in gassing his people so but this is a
president who unlike our last president
is transparent about wanting to meet
with with President Putin the last
president whispered in a hot mic hey
after the next election I'll have some
flexibility so if there are national
security concern to the things these two
these two countries can work on together
than the president's willing to hear
that but he does it transparently for
all the world to see and I think it's
been another very successful week for
this president between the sixth
anniversary in soups month anniversary
the tax cuts the ability to fill another
Supreme Court vacancy through the
retirement of Justice Kennedy the
announcement of another major summit
with another world leader this is a
president trying to bring precent
prosperity to all the world beginning
here at home and he's succeeding
Kellyanne Conway thank you so much for
joining us and I really appreciate